natalie is with us in New York hi
Natalie how are you hi how are you babe
you so much for taking my call
sure what's up in your world so I am
recently married just a few months and
we are talking a lot about our finances
I paid off my student debt a little
while ago and now now we have his to
work on it's it's three hundred thousand
oh my god is he a doctor or a lawyer
he's a doctor
okay so what is what is your household
income now well it's about 2:30 good
good so you're gonna live on nothing and
pay that off real fast right yes he's
finishing residency so you know my
income is 150 and his is about like 70
other residents so we're looking at job
opportunities in two different areas and
they they offer them one piece about
five hundred thousand one job is
$500,000 Network yes okay but in a an
unidentified to take you know a job that
pays that much more just to get out of
debt quicker and kind of postponed okay
so job number one pays what in john
number two pays what about 850 versus
350 okay and you make 150 would you make
150 at either one of those locations
maybe a little less um no maybe 100 okay
okay so that's kind of either place
you'd make about a hundred so you'll
even you'd leave New York City well in
either case and so what is the less than
ideal location that's 500 grand more
that's
[Music]
kind of in the tundra it's up north you
know Canada in Canada no near Canada
United States yeah so he's a surgeon so
once he completes training you know they
offer some of these these jobs in you
know underserved areas yeah are a lot
more money yeah I never heard of half a
million more but that I mean I knew
underserved would overpay I knew that
but are they asking for a length of time
commitment yeah they asked for three
years okay and you would be willing to
do the three years I'm not sure why work
I want to know well you already live in
New York City it's not like you live in
the south I mean you're used to cold
weather but it's just kind of a whole
lot of unis okay alright so they're just
not out your yeah so you're moving to a
very room a very rural location versus
New York City's that's a big culture
shock I got you good all right well I
mean I don't know you got to ask
yourself that question you're gonna be
making four hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in a worst-case scenario right
exactly and so my god I mean if you
can't pay off three hundred thousand in
the first year somebody ought to smack
both of you if you can't live on a
hundred and fifty thousand somebody
ought to smack you really don't you
think house you have three hundred
thousand dollars of student loan debt
you need to clean up so I mean if you go
make four hundred fifty thousand I think
you're gonna work this out you could be
debt-free in one year and the next year
you buy a house and the next year you
know do you do some other stuff I mean
just have a little bit of patience with
that kind of shovel you ought to be able
to move anything you want to around so
the other way you come out a million and
a half ahead a half million dollars
times three for three years but you're
you know you're in the tundra you know
you could buy a whole lot of airline
tickets out of the tundra and come visit
go visit New York City every week yeah
every weekend and come out ahead yeah
because we're little sortes we were
worried about you not having any
retirement savings not having anything
yet
you'll be okay you're gonna be making a
half million dollars a year as long as
you don't go spending and play do stupid
doctor tricks with the money and you
know go another four hundred thousand in
debt to do something else but if you
guys will just stay debt-free
you're gonna have tons of money to
invest you're gonna be fine
you start banking 200 grand a year
you're not quick you have a million
dollars it's like four years you know
you're okay
you're gonna be all right you know as
long as you don't keep you know jack
your lifestyle way up so the only thing
I would take I would take the four
hundred and fifty thousand dollar
cheaper job if you're committed to
getting out of debt in one year mm-hmm
if you're not you need to go do the
other one I think we could do it in one
year maybe two I think you can do it in
one I really do I mean not plus or minus
taxes taxes might push you into two but
I don't want you to check your lifestyle
up or start doing a bunch of other stuff
do you get this deck cleaned up no job
ones get the debt gone before you do
anything else don't talk to me about
buying a house buying a car don't buy
anything
you're broke and in debt hundreds of
thousands of dollars clean that mess up
and then you're free to live the rest of
your life and do whatever you want now
the only thing that if Sharon and I were
looking at this my wife and I were
looking at this situation we would
consider the tundra opportunity but we
would put in there
a couple hundred thousand dollars or a
hundred thousand dollars out of that
five hundred and travel and we would
just bug out of there virtually every
weekend yeah well as a surgeon that's
not as easy I guess he's gonna have a
lot of coal and everything he's not he's
not on seven days a week
I know okay so I mean just jump on the
plane and go I mean even if you charter
a plane out of there you can go you you
know you can have a life is my point and
you don't have to define your life as
like your
on the moon and you can't come home yeah
you know you can jump on a plane and be
anywhere in some period of hours you
know and and and just you know enjoy
some downtime head down to the Caribbean
head down to Cabo for the weekend I
don't care
mm-hmm you know you can do a lot of that
kind of stuff on a half million bucks
and still come out ahead if you wanted
to play that that's how we would play it
because I'm like you a lot of money yeah
I mean I'm pretty relaxed nowadays but
if I were your age and I was concerned
about you know New York type of
activities you know then that's a way to
do it is to budget it and still say okay
we're gonna spend 50 grand on travel a
year or 75 grand on travel a year and
that's our way of dealing with the fact
that we're in the tundra and we're
making all this extra money for at least
three years
mm-hm and if you want to do that that's
a way to make it palatable I'm not sure
I would I think if you're making 450 you
ought to be able to ah to be okay and
you'll probably make not 450 for all
three years probably make 450 the first
year your income will probably go up his
income will probably go up the second
year so you probably back up over half
me and easy between the two of you then
so but kiddo whatever you do get rid of
debt before you do anything else
do not go buy a house those debts come
do not go buy a car until this debts
gone you hear me loud and clear on that
I'm gonna call you stupid if you do
straight to your face this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]